Michael you were watching the Victory
Day Parade unfold it was scaled back so
what did we see then yes uh well we saw
a speech by President Putin we saw the
t-34 tank this always leads the parade
which is the Old Second World War iconic
tank the tank that drove its way to
Berlin that's always given Pride a place
but not much else
um of a sort of token group of armored
vehicles not really very much and then a
a series of nuclear
systems like this one some of the big
icbms intercontinental ballistic
missiles they always show these off and
that's important and that was about it
really in terms of military material not
very much a 45-minute
ceremony instead of a two-hour ceremony
a very a very a very predictable speech
by President Putin but nothing new in
that and and the crowds were not allowed
to get very close normally the crowds
push in because they want to see all
this stuff they want to see the parade
and they were kept away from it Diana in
Moscow I corresponded there she said it
was very difficult for the crowd to get
close enough so it was all very
underwhelming to be honest and I was
astonished at finished at 45 minutes we
were settling in for a two-hour look at
all of this material no over in 45
minutes I'm just always Blown Away by
the scale of the the missiles in
comparison to the people lining the
roots it just gives you an impression of
just how huge they are so that's what we
did see what didn't we see because as
she said Victory Day is normally the set
piece of the year it's a long speech
it's a huge display what was missing
well we didn't see what we normally see
is all the tanks I mean this is a
previous year I think there was the
previous uh last year of 2021s and we
normally see the modern tanks so we see
the 234s the famous tank that's like
their Spitfire of the second world war
so we see that leading the parade and
then we see all their modern tanks so
the the t-72s the t80s the t90s the
Armada tank the T14 the brand new tank
that they like to show off a couple of
uh years ago and we didn't see any tanks
whatsoever is that because they're all
in action nope I mean they say Well
they're all in Ukraine but I mean you
can always get a squadron of Tanks
together for a parade they obviously
took a decision not to put tanks on the
streets we didn't see a fly past and
again the crowd loved that they love to
see the Air Force there everybody likes
a flyback no fly past last year there
was no flight as they said it was
because the weather was bad which wasn't
true and this year the weather was
absolutely perfect in Moscow no fly past
here or in Petersburg which is the other
of the the big parades and of course 21
parades throughout Russia were also
canceled on security grounds and so we
see them marching we see the the troops
themselves I love the uniforms these are
the ozarish uniforms the offices look
great I think that the ranks look pretty
poor but the officers their uniforms are
lovely I really like that and their
Anthem is the old zarist Anthem much
better than the old Soviet one so a
paired back display and also from what I
gather less emotion as well this year
yes the thing we didn't see which
everybody likes to see the Russians like
to do this the the Regiment of the
Immortals members of the public are
invited to bring photographs of the
those who died in war in service of the
motherland and this is from Petersburg
last year and this is the emotional
punch of the parade after all of the the
equipment after all the marching then
these are those who've given their lives
and that's a really emotional moment
it's canceled all together now whether
it's because people might turn up with
photographs of people who've been killed
in this war might be difficult or they
might have turned up and be turned away
not allowed to show them and that would
have got out that would have caused a
lot of disgruntlement maybe it's just
because it reminds the Russians too much
of the people who are losing in war
they've lost in total casualties at
least 220 000 people dead and seriously
wounded and so this year they didn't do
this at all and they've lost in that the
thing that reaches out and grabs
Russians by the heart this is the thing
they really go for it's the parade of
the Immortals nothing
okay Michael thank you and Professor
Michael Clark there